[Music]
[Applause]
all right we'll get to phone calls
coming up settle on our poll question is
well our good buddy Nick Wright first
things first co-host and every weekdays
at three Eastern on Fox Sports 1
alongside Chris Broussard and Kevin
wilds and uh Nick good to see you buddy
how are you good to see you it's been
too long uh you know I was wondering we
were still good buddies I hadn't been
invited back on in quite some time which
was a shame because I would like to
thank Paulie because at the very end of
my last appearance right after you said
goodbye Paulie said kind of trailing
into the microphone he's so awesome
every time and it touched my heart so
thank you very much Paulie and to the
whole crew I have no recollection
yeah I'd need to hear something some
audio evidence I've thought of Nick and
his appearances on the show I don't
recall him saying that but maybe it
wasn't Paulie maybe it was someone
someone in the back row or in the back
Studio said something very very nice
about me afterwards yeah because off air
Paul's usually complaining about having
Nick on so often that
there's no audio of that
enough did anybody say anything nice
about Nick Wright the last time he was
on the last one happened
the last time why would I make this up I
was trying to thank somebody
I like we don't give compliments and we
don't take compliments especially what a
weird lie that would be like oh here's
I'm gonna start my DP show appearance by
thanking them for something that didn't
happen and and the I mean it just it
makes no sense we'll check the tape
we'll check the tape yes not the Marconi
I will say this this appearance is off
to a great start yeah so you're right
there yeah okay thank you Paulie anytime
let's bring on Nick Wright from uh first
things first yeah every weekday and
what's right with Nick Wright the
podcast oh you can see him okay oh look
at that got signage there I like signage
yeah yeah it's nice that's what the kids
what do you want to talk about Dan
um
if uh the bills lose tonight dot dot
what's that mean big picture
I mean it just like so many things in
the sports world that the only person
who had it right was Nick Wright it'll
be nice it'll be a nice consistent thing
the I am listen I have my weaknesses as
an analyst but you know what my Str you
know what I think I'm the best in the
world at maybe it's because of the size
of my nose sniffing out fraudulent teams
three years ago everyone's like oh it's
the Clippers sitting now it's like okay
no it's not the last few years the Nets
oh the next year Nets and this year the
Bills were treated from the very first
game of the year when they were Road
favorites against the defending Champion
Rams now the Rams end up being terrible
uh like they had proven something
they've proven nothing the bills last
year were worse by any metric than the
bills the year prior the bills came into
this season with amazing momentum
because they blew a playoff game they
had a lead-in with 13 seconds of kicking
off I've never seen anything like it and
then through five weeks everyone was
like oh my god well I might as well call
the season Josh Allen qb1 the Bill's
best offense in defense and it's just
not they're they're not that and so it
wouldn't shock me if they lose they
should have lost on Thanksgiving they're
a fine team they are a good football
team that was anointed this Juggernaut
despite the fact that we've never seen
it and their the people are trying to
make the comparison of Josh Allen's last
month of football when since week seven
he has the same passer rating and the
same touchdown interception ratio is
Davis Mills to what Patrick Mahomes went
through last year and those are
identical passwording and touching on
reception issue to what Mahomes went
through last year the difference is
Mahomes had three and a half years of
perfect football and then a slump Josh
Allen's career has been
awful as a rookie
oh maybe there's something there as a
second year player outstanding in the
Third Year MVP candidate not even a pro
bowler last year Mac Jones made the Pro
Bowl Josh Allen did not and then a great
playoff run where he lost one of his two
games and then this year awesome for six
weeks and awful for six weeks it's just
so I I the Bill's discussion irritates
me if you can tell I can tell and I said
this a couple of weeks ago that there's
certain players who get to that point
where we then start to take them for
granted and Mahomes had moved into that
category where you almost expect him you
plug in 40 touchdown passes you know
he's going to get to the AFC title game
and it's not fair to him he loses Tyree
kill and he's still probably the leading
candidate for MVP can you see other
players in other sports who get into it
doesn't take long to get into that oh
that's right like The Greek Freak is is
in that category now know yeah uh Luca
is kind of he hadn't won an MVP yet
there but but there's certain players I
know basketball is a forte for you but
do you see other players who we they we
take them for granted and then they
almost have to reinvent themselves for
us to go oh my God that's right
so The Greek Freak is a great example
because LeBron is what people would go
to but LeBron
hadn't you know took him a bit of time
to win he didn't win a title until his
eighth year or ninth year in the league
pardon me uh he went to a couple but
didn't win and didn't play great in
those first couple finals he went to in
fact played really poorly in one of them
Giannis is one where I think Giannis
should have won MVP last year he didn't
could have won it the year before he
didn't and it was because at least for
one of them he hadn't yet won the title
so we were holding it against him here's
my frustration with the Mahomes thing
typically when we take those guys for
granted the there are a couple good
things that go along with it one is they
are universally accepted as the best
player in the sport going into this year
Mahomes was number eight on the NFL top
100 at the NFL.com had him as the number
four quarterback we had folks saying he
was the second or third really second
best in his own division it's all of
that so he doesn't he and and it was it
was conventional wisdom that Josh Allen
had supplanted him as qb1 because
everyone wants to use that terminology
because all these guys want to be Scouts
evidently they use qb1 is qb2 so stupid
but the uh here's the other thing that
usually happens
you usually that comes after you've won
multiple MVPs so what in the NFL guys
who win multiple usually win them in
bunches far won three in a row Manning
won back to back and then there was a
gap Brady had only a two-year Gap Rogers
had only a two-year Gap Montana I think
won back to back if Mahomes doesn't win
this year it'll be four years where he
didn't win it in 2020
he had 38 touchdowns six picks he was 14
and one as a starter
and they didn't give him the MVP because
he didn't play in week 17 because his
team had locked everything up and he was
the defending Super Bowl champion that
yeah so I guess Dan here's my take
Patrick Mahomes wildly underrated that's
what I I believe that I actually I
believe that
I I don't disagree with that I I
absolutely I I think because he lost
Tyreek Hill that will strengthen his MVP
resume and what they've done this year I
remember an analyst saying the Chiefs
wouldn't make the playoffs and I thought
wow that that's saying a lot but also
and but and it was it was it was
relative conventional wisdom that they
wouldn't win the division saying they
wouldn't make the playoffs was you and
people anointed the Chargers and then
and I like the charges a lot this year
as well to be fair and folks acted like
the Broncos were gonna be that were you
know good which was crazy uh the it's
very it's very frustrating and here's
the last thing on this
the year starts and it's Josh Allen's
MVP right before A Game's been played
and then it's Alan versus Mahomes and
then Alan falls off and now it's Hertz
versus Mahomes and mark my words Dan in
three weeks you know what's going to be
on all the shows like mine with the
little topic bars on the bottom
why isn't two a tongue of iloa The
League MVP and the answer is because
he's not Patrick Mahomes but they have
to have a foil to the best player in the
league and that's what they're going to
do throughout the year but we also want
to move to the next we're in a hurry to
move to the next we got to find the next
you know it we moved on almost from Josh
Allen to all of a sudden it's Joe burrow
or Justin Herbert like where where are
we going now and I think we're in this
rush to be ahead of everybody else we're
talking to a Nick Wright first things
first co-host on Fox Sports One and
what's right with Nick Wright his
podcast there as well do we have the
audio the last time that Nick Wright was
on polling yeah October 21st Nick Wright
was on and here's how the interview
ended okay
I'll talk to you next time see ya my
best to your wife
that dude's the best that's good he's
good talented guy Satan all right well
you're lucky you're a lot more sensitive
than yeah you thought maybe it was
Paulie and I was like well Polly doesn't
say anything nice I'd like an apology
all right you know what I retract that
well you know what I don't want to
defame the brand Polly's built over 20
years respect of wearing incredibly ugly
shirts eating at really odd restaurants
and being just the best producer in the
sports business so there you go Paulie
well said uh why is it open season on
you're welcome by the way thank you
Seaton oh there you go okay why is it
open season on Russell Wilson
so this is fascinating
I
I think
that
the general sports fan this isn't
necessarily my cup of tea but what the
general sports fan wants is
the
uh a touch of fake meaning these guys
are rich and famous incredibly confident
and they want a little humility right
they want a little fake I I would prefer
authentic
you know jerk to fake nice guy but that
that's I'm out of the mainstream right
Russell Wilson but what nobody wants is
transparently fake what nobody wants is
dude do we what you rehearsed this you
clearly don't believe what you're saying
and Russell Wilson has crossed the
Rubicon of
No One Believes you ever
and he seems to at times even on the
sideline getting yelled at by Purcell
that he is going through and I know this
is psychoanalysis and it's not fair but
it's what my gut is he instead of
reacting like the competitor that he is
he's taking the extra beat of how would
the Russell Wilson character respond
here and which is why he's like yeah
okay okay like I think people you know
what I think could have turned at least
partially the Russell Wilson stuff is it
when Purcell yelled at him he took his
helmet off and yelled back hey man
whatever it is uh and it also didn't
help that Nathaniel Hackett was a foot
away saying like oh boy it sounds like
something's going on back there boys
um but I think that he that he everyone
thinks he's fake and I don't think
people like fake and it doesn't help
that he's been horrible yeah but it is
shocking to me how much schadenfreude
everyone that has played with him seems
to be taking in this that from Carol to
it's not just Richard Sherman and Doug
Baldwin it's everybody seems to want to
you know take an extra shot of them up
to it including but even The Wristband
thing I don't know if you guys noticed
this I'm sure you did but I don't know
if you talked about it so The Wristband
mini controversy happens
and then two days later he's at the
press conference
wearing a wristband
and it's like buddy like that's come on
like and so I don't know I agree with
you uh when Purcell yells at him what
now not many Marquee quarterbacks Frank
franchise quarterbacks get dressed down
by a defensive lineman
you could see him kind of go
wait what
and instead of grabbing Purcell by the
shoulder pads and like banging helmets
and going yes let's go whatever it might
be I agree with you I mentioned that he
he seemed shocked and then didn't know
how to react to that because he didn't
have time to prepare to prepare yeah
right that's the thing is that's what
you you tell your kids which is and it's
not you tell your kids I mean it's an
old thing which is if you don't lie you
don't ever have to remember anything you
know what I mean you just you just you
ask a question you tell the truth you
don't have to think if you're always
yourself or more often than not yourself
you can just react
and I don't think he feels comfortable
doing that and I it's I don't know at
this point it you almost feel badly for
the guy yeah because in addition to
everyone going after him uh listen I
thought he was a player on the decline
you know one of my strongest bets this
year was the Broncos under I didn't
believe in him but nobody myself
included thought
they would be the worst offense in
football and every week is the same
that's the other frustrating thing for a
Broncos fan it's not like okay one week
they figured it out and scored 30. every
week they score 16 points every week
they're you know I mean they're three
yards of pass it's just it's the same
script no matter who the opponent is we
created a t-shirt the Broncos t-shirt
fritzy uh you want to give Nick what the
t-shirt is run run incomplete punt Let's
Ride
yeah because who's the I apologize is
fritzy's the Broncos yeah yeah
you know fritzy
that the Broncos went 47 years
without back-to-back losing Seasons yeah
and now they're six in a row
it's hard man
yeah that's right that's what you get
you guys were mean to me you it might
have been your father mean to me at
Arrowhead Stadium when I was a child and
you guys would come in there with old
John Elway and Shannon sharp and kick
our ass and beat us in the playoffs when
we were 13 and three and Elway drive
down the field and you guys were mean to
me as a child and now it's finally
coming back to haunt you we have the
greatest quarterback to ever live you
guys have a quarter of a billion dollars
in Mr quite limited how's that feel and
we haven't beaten you guys in like seven
years at least Paul it's 14 games in a
row the Broncos are this bad they
haven't played the Chiefs yet they have
two left against us Paul what did you
think of Nick Wright's appearances I
love to Rave about it but we're all out
of time that's a shame darn it
even Seton doesn't have pleasure hey uh
it's great to see you again
you as well um happy holidays hope you
guys all did had a wonderful time
I hope you're feeling better Dan well
maybe we'll have you on before the big
day
wait I would love that wait
why can't we have money of course we can
I always offer I always say how about
Nick and then Paulie goes I don't know
nothing there
let me see if Reggie answers first and
then we can call him
see you all right thank you Nick that's
uh Nick Wright first things first